[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
somehow we make the smooth segue to
diana rossini the espn nfl reporter
and she'll be part of sportscenter's
special today nfl free agency countdown
today and tomorrow at 3 eastern on espn
you had the opportunity to bow out if
you wanted to after that last segment
diana so i do appreciate you holding on
for dear life here and joining this
program no way
uh i was laughing i was listening uh and
i was working at the same time so
you were distracting me a bit i had a
couple of typos in my text messages so
if i get any info wrong today i would
hope that this show steps up
and uh just takes full blame for for you
know
getting me off the the ball here because
you know it's still
early here we got a lot of action dan
all right uh you have the uh special
today
just based off what has happened so far
in free agency what will be the lead
story on espn's sportscenter special on
free agency
for for today yeah i think the wide
receiver market and the corner market is
going to start taking off
um it was really quiet yesterday
which i i wasn't really surprised
because i knew those past rushers were
going to be flying off because every
team seemed like they were in on that
and
wanted a piece of it um
look we can talk about all the pieces of
these free agents and
the fits and and and who the big players
are and the big names
but at the end of all this i still think
the quarterback conversation
is the biggest one which is it sounds
predictable but
i think this off season especially
knowing desean watson's situation not
being happy
this russell wilson situation in seattle
that i could comfortably call
not happy chicago bears haven't done
anything at the quarterback position
the jets seem open to trading sam
darnold so
if something were to happen there
obviously that's going to be our lead
uh and it could dan it could something
could happen today with that
yeah i wonder about sam darnold i
mentioned this last hour that he could
really change
quite a few things if sam darnold's
traded
where is he traded to um you know could
it be seattle
if you don't get a quarterback in return
for the bears then i got sam darnold
who's 23 years of age
and i don't know the possibility of that
because i know seattle doesn't want to
russ won't go to the jets but could you
get sam darnold
and still capitalize on a desperate
chicago bears organization
yeah and that seems to be the tone of
the trade of it actually happening it's
all about desperation what
what the chicago bears are willing to
give up and
and i look at it like this maggie and
and and pace are essentially on one-year
deals now right they need
they need to win so if you're them
what do you care about mortgaging in the
future you're just trying to keep your
job
so everything is on the table there in
chicago i know that
they are looking at every single option
but here's the problem when when these
talks started
to pick up i'd say about two weeks ago
in regards to seattle actually picking
up the call
actually listening to offers i had a
team
that i was talking to that i know was
interested and they said look
forget the cat pit stop getting all
caught up on that and it's funny this
one gm said i saw you on tv today and
i'm not saying you sounded dumb but you
sounded different
yeah which is always my favorite i'm
like oh thank you um
you can maneuver around cap hits don't
don't get caught up in that and it was a
good lesson to just remember that when
we're talking about these things
because i i do think everyone gets
bogged down of you know why would
seattle do that why would they
apparently they can make that work
that's not the issue
the issue is seattle just doesn't have
the answer at quarterback
they're okay with dealing they want to
play
just what's their answer and that seems
to be the biggest
issue right now when it comes to that
actually going down
if i'm the bears i go after desean
watson though diana
because i got a guy seven years younger
and if i'm gonna
put everything on the table and whatever
you want
desean watson's already under contract
russ is going to go to the bears and go
oh by the way i'd like to be the second
highest paid quarterback in the league
which nobody's talking about
russ isn't going there to play for his
old salary
what do you think about the bears all in
on dushan instead
yeah russ is going to get paid here's
the problem with deshawn and i hate
continually saying the same thing
because everyone keeps hearing it and
it's frustrating houston is not trading
deshaun watson
they're not doing it at this point right
now and
the the closer you're looking at the
calendar is the league year is coming
and you start thinking if they
going to make a move if they're going to
be forced to make a move later in the
year
they're gonna they need to start
thinking about this now but the problem
is everyone i've spoken to
who has interest in desean watson which
you could assume it's a lot of teams
right now have told me
that caserio is a pro
and he's polite uh he's he's open to
talking
but you bring up watson and a trade
offer
and the conversation ends there they're
not
even willing to go there and i spoke to
to a couple players that are on the free
agent market even some
players that have recently signed with
houston
and as much as i was
kind of quick to congratulate them on
signing in houston even though it kind
of felt like it felt a little phony
um i i i was curious of well what did
they tell you
about who's gonna play quarterback you
know like you're signing with the new
team
yeah you want your money but you wanna i
mean if i'm a player i want to know what
the situation is
and it's it's funny it's management is
telling players
desean will be here and the players who
all talk to deshawn are saying
deshawn is digging in he is digging in
and willing not to play
yeah we're talking to diana rossini you
can see her part of the espn sports
center special that'll be at three
eastern today
nfl free agency countdown the saints
situation we got sean payton on next
hour but
does is somebody in front of somebody
there with the quarterbacking situation
with jameis now
coming back and uh taysom hill still
there in camp
which i sent coach payton a text message
early this morning i said
thank god i'm going first here i mean
i don't know who books the show but
they're brilliant because the last
person i want to follow is is sean
payton he's he's dynamic and
uh brilliant and entertaining and so so
thank you guys for helping me out here
but uh does he have a starting
quarterback
i think he does i i think he should i
think
he thinks he does sean will will
is gonna fill your heir in about an hour
with how much he loves jameis winston
and i will always say if i could find
one person in my life
who loves me as much as sean payton
loves taysom hell
you know i probably would have been
married years ago instead of waiting
late in my life here uh because he truly
does he and
so it's so it's so interesting speaking
to the team
and to coach about that dynamic
the quarterback position because she
really likes both of them and i think
jameis
challenges them and and and coach is one
of these guys he
he loves taking a player like
jamis who who really has that natural
ability and coaching him up and teaching
him the way
you know to be a more decisive more
accurate type passer
and and the players on the saints have
always told me always from i mean we're
going back to camp
how incredible jameis is as just you
know being part of that organization
because that's one of the strongest
locker rooms
of any teams in the nfl without a doubt
um
so it's going to be from what i
understand it's going to be a
quarterback competition come this summer
he's going to make them compete that
compete and and have at it and see who
who comes out but i i think coach is in
a great position here because
you know you can play either of these
guys if jameis becomes a starter
you have taste them playing in this sort
of utility position
i mean pretty much playing everywhere
for him so um
we'll see but but i i was told it's
going to be a competition
does your husband love you as much as
sean payton loves taysom hill
no okay my husband loves the eagles
that's about it it ends there it's
it's it's so funny this this whole free
agency thing dan is is such a
weird part of of your job as an nfl
reporter because it's
it's such a love hate thing because love
it's adam schafter and ian rappaport as
much as i like to come on here and be
like i'm a big news breaker i get the
little guys once in a while i get the
big fish but
i get paid to really cover the game
during the season
um and i enjoy it but the problem is
i love to compete and i i love
messing with i love adam schechter i'm
all the respect in the world but i enjoy
trying to get a couple from him when i
and he's open to it he knows what i'm
doing all the time he's like go for it
die
go um but just your life
monday through friday during free agency
it's it's so unhealthy
you know like i i told my husband on
sunday said don't expect any food
don't expect water in the house uh we're
in the middle of a move
our place is a dump right now and so i
guess he does love me enough to
understand and support me here
but it's really a sick part of this job
that i
i enjoy and i may love this more than
him so we're even
why do we assume the patriots know what
they're doing in free agency
i don't know why we do i think bill
belichick would give him all the credit
because he's he's the greatest coach of
all time
but i'm watching this spending spree
here
and it's here's bill parcells taught me
this years ago
he said stop trying to figure out what
teams are gonna do
the answers right in front of you nobody
changes their style
it's they go by the history of what they
do for example we know the colts they've
got so much money right now
they're not spending any money in free
agency they never do
so it's exactly what bill says
so then you look at new england here and
it's like i mean
no offense parcells you're wrong here
because they are not doing what they
what they normally do
they're going outside the box but
i didn't think they had any money though
diane remember when brady was there and
then
like they've they've they've spent they
got 137 million dollars in guarantees
right now
that they that they've spent in less
than 24 hours
where's that money where is that where's
it coming from two superb tight ends too
yeah johnny smith hunter henry like
these guys these are legit
tight ends and you know originally when
yesterday meaning when i started to see
the signings you know he picks up a guy
from miami picks up
you know johnny smith from tennessee and
you're putting the connections you know
these are
these are players who have been in sort
of that new england system with mike
grebel in tennessee and
ryan flores in miami there's there's not
gonna be a culture shock
you know when when they arrive in new
england so i thought that was smart and
you know a lot of the beat reporters
have been doing a great job of digging
up
a lot of the quotes that uh belichick
has had on these players and
he's had this like love affair with all
these free agents that nobody even knew
about until now that we've discovered
they're finding what they have money
they have they obviously
have a lot of it yeah but forget what
they're doing
this is all so interesting and fun but
who
is the quarterback that that to me
they can make they can sign every pro
player
that's on the market but to me i don't
think cam newton's the answer
i think he's a placeholder until they
figure out what they want to do and
historically
not that they're sticking with that
script but we know what bill does he
drafts
mid-round you know we've seen it ryan
merritt jared stidham jamie garoppolo
you know these are mid-round guys
and that's usually where they go for a
quarterback granted they had tom brady
up this year so they didn't really need
to go but
but that i just think this is really
interesting that they're building as if
they've got a guy there
thanks for joining us thanks for putting
up with us and uh have fun today on the
uh the special the sports center special
at three eastern
nfl free agency countdown diana thank
you for joining us good luck with the
move
and hopefully uh that the free agency
period you survive
uh your marriage survives that yeah
thank you just uh give coach payton a
little shout out for me say hey racini
says
you can't keep up with her even if you
try to be entertaining no i'm going to
say
that sean loves taysom hill more
than diana's husband loves her oh he's
fully aware of that shaw was invited to
my wedding and
all that he he knows my marriage is on
the wrong
thank you diana thanks guys that's uh
diana rossini nfl
reporter for the mothership